[Música]
[Aplausos]
o time dos outros
é um prazer estar aqui muito honrado com
o convite e com muitos dos outros eu vim
falar do futuro futuro agora é e faz
parte da associação de futurologia não
tem nada a ver com o sangue tem que ver
com perspectiva e prospectiva tem que
ver com construir futuro quando o uso
dos dias que você não estiver no próprio
pensar o podia partilhar convosco
achei que devia para criar aquilo que
acha inspirador no futuro dos dias que
valem mas também falar um pouco dos
medos incertezas que encontro
nessa altura que eu acho que não devem
assustar mas no mínimo devemos ter a
guarda dos presos nesse sentindo as
prudentes avisado ouvir as palavras as
palavras do padre antónio vieira que
dizia que não foi pedido para falar de
tudo seu disquinhos falar sobre
construtores do futuro as pessoas que
constroem futuros alguns deus nós temos
um náuticos outros nos loucos mas sá
carneiro de rico loucura uma questão de
convenção ou seja louco são os que estão
em número inferior
o antonio baldin sonhou esta catedral e
morreu antes de ver construída
ela ainda hoje está a ser construída tem
esse aspecto incluindo na cabeça
abel esta catedral existiu exatamente
assim linda
os cursos das catedrais ao longo dos
séculos foram sempre pessoas que querem
parar temos nunca viram os seus
edifícios construídos
é portanto de algumas dessas pessoas que
eu vou falar aqui hoje
pessoas que estão ligadas à construção
do futuro muitos anos
iam ser presente e pra falar sobre o
futuro o suor cinco palavras não falam
muita coisa forte em algumas coisas
ao falar do custo marginal 0
muito ligado a palestrante de hoje vamos
vencer porque vamos falar sobre a sua
versão da computação em particular em
direção à computação quântica
vamos falar sobre as novas fronteiras
das ciências da vida e depois vou falar
sobre aspectos nossos filhos e
conhecimento e também sobre uma palavra
que é muito carvão possível empatia
vou terminar o emblema mais gosto muito
e vamos perceber na altura porque eu
achei que era importante terminar com
com a espanha
vamos começar tudo o custo marginal
feira a revista forbes tem um indicador
chamado espírito do elenco
quanto tempo demorou um bilionário a
fazer o seu primeiro bilhão
quanto tempo demorou o fel a atingir seu
primeiro milhão 27 anos quanto tempo
durou o zuckerberg atingir seu primeiro
milhão quatro anos
quanto tempo morou o tipo do grupo a
atingir seu primeiro milhão oito meses
pré colonial
isso não quer dizer que o mark
zuckerberg seja mais inclusivo que ora
quer dizer que na altura do rockfeller
não havia a sua versão digital
não havia produtos do custo marginal 0
só copiam e são do tipo de propriedade
intelectual e não tem custo marginal
eu estava desafiará a compreender em que
estamos a caminho de uma sociedade que
não tem só no digital produtos de custo
zero variava 10 nós também tem no mundo
físico produtos marginal zero porque
porque merecia uma técnica chamada
trilha e printing que permite por
manufaturar detivesse tratativa o
literalmente fazer cópias de objetos a
partir de uma especificação digital
imaginem uma coisa que não existe a
chamada mp 8 e imagina que o partido de
um formato de oito g8 podem imprimir
qualquer um
isso significa que o custo marginal o
mundo físico vai também ao tender para
zero em particular nanotecnologia com
uma técnica chamada a pm
atualmente por sigilo e factoring nós
vamos poder construir objetos físicos
atum atum
tudo isso parece perto agora para o
ordenamento científica
eu só queria chamar a vossa atenção para
uma coisa é que sempre que a economia
marginal verão a um único ganhador no
mundo um ou dois
vamos dar exemplos mercado das duas
pesquisas a quota de mercado da google
88% ilumina quota de mercado
85 santo sempre que há um mercado com
custo marginal zero a um ou dois
ganhadores no mundo
isso significa que o mundo é franca
menos igual
nessas categorias e isso é muito
perigoso para o equilíbrio social do
mundo quer dizer que por um lado mexida
e me inspira ver todos estes eventos
novas tecnologias que espera ainda ver
em vida mas também consigo perceber as
consequências do que isso significa para
a sociedade
deixa eu dar o exemplo isto ainda não é
uma ponta e a um museu
já um modelo de uma escala grande poça
estão a ver isto é como nós vamos
construir pontes nos próximos anos um
álbum há vu é imprimir 3d
o outro lado é imprimir 3d e ponto faz
com dois voos
esta ponte é estruturalmente mais forte
que os pontos que hoje usamos ainda só
uma ponta museu mas não admira nada que
daqui a 10 anos e uma ponta real porque
espera é importante por 4% da população
mundial trabalha em construção quatro
sendo que todos os homens e mulheres do
mundo trabalham na indústria da
construção
ruth zara construção tá impacto social
estamos a falar de uma pessoa que gosta
de tecnologia gosto muito é com vir a
ser que um dia perceber os homens
tudo que fazemos é para servir os homens
se não for para servir os homens algo
muito pouco
vamos lá então um exemplo ainda mais
nova e vou citar um terno técnico surgir
violento que vai joão já não virão com
certeza que há muitas pessoas nesta sala
que já viram esse tempo
estamos a falar de um senhor chamado
anthony atala quanto o natal a trabalhar
20 anos a procurar imprimir rins
imprimir com técnica 3d e matri soar
rins artificiais por causa do trabalho
este homem muitos jovens homens e
mulheres estão vivos à custa e um
transplante com um rim artificial
quero dizer que acredito que em 2030
anos tanto grêmio como pâncreas serão
produzidos desta maneira não haverá
coletas para transplante e vamos acabar
se tudo correr bem com essa onda odiosa
odiosa palavra coisa que é o tráfico de
órgãos
não consigo pensar em coisas muito mais
abjetas que o tráfego órgãos
esse senhor não sei se alguma vez trará
prémio nobel da medicina pelos pra mim
já é candidato ao seu adversário o tempo
todo revela portanto de algo que é
impactante na sociedade não é uma mera
nova tecnologia é algo mais que isso não
tenha consciência que esta forma que
está bem mais computação têm mais poder
de computação tudo aquilo que for
necessário para colocar um homem na lua
voces todo ano com super com todos no
bolso que só usam por exemplo holística
99 5% da computação é usada já não
estica já representa um atentado a uma
utilização de computação quando aqui
muitos anos tivermos um pouco mais de
sobriedade vamos perceber quando atrás
que era muito pouco disciplinados
da computação nós chamamos de quem quer
fácil mas de facto eu chamo-lhe má
utilização do poder computacional
este estudo eu a fifa só trabalhar só
mesmo trabalhar com a senhora
extraordinária chamada nelly cruz foi
comissária europeia das comunicações
esse era chamada de dama de ferro 2 é
essa senhora de 72 anos na altura
trabalhar com ela e eu às vezes ficava
pensavam a vela não confesso foco em
falta de energia mas ao haver weah ao eu
era definitivamente muito menos
energético na altura que vai punir a ver
com ela estudar este estudo produzido
pelo ministério oxford que diz que 47%
das profissões todas as profissões podem
ser alto mas nos próximos dez anos o que
não quer dizer que não serão tomadas
quer dizer que são automóveis
gosto de dizer que este facto é muito
relevante nós estávamos habituados a que
a alteração era sempre dos outros
nunca nos acontecer nós vamos dar um
exemplo simples
imaginem um problema grave de um tumor
na cabeça
o tumor profundo não oficial
o cirurgião mais seguro para a
intervencionar esse tumor já não é um
homem é um ovo ou chamada a 20
o cirurgião mais seguro do mundo para
intervencionar um tumor na cabeça não é
um homem em um computador chama-se da 20
já não estamos lado a automação do
simples estamos a falar do complexo
estamos a falar da automação porque
infelizmente nós vamos assistir ainda
mais evoluções muito vocês conheceram
pedro domingos pedro domingos
se houvesse um novel do enem 2009
escreveu um livro chamado master
algoritmo que unifica todas as teorias
mais singular nem do mundo e que acha
que existe um único ao currículo
completo que é capaz de aprender a
partir de qualquer conjunto
esta descoberta é mais importante que
tive para lá de virada tem mais impacto
no mundo quer dizer que a gente possa
aprender qualquer coisa para qualquer
conjunto os lados
o pedro é mesmo uma pessoa muito
importante no mundo
agora imaginem que a sensibilização do
mundo é fácil o custo de cada vez mais
barato
imagine o que pode fazer com aquilo
mais uma coisa vai agregar todos quantos
anos têm computadores quânticos talvez
menos não ser pelo menos 10 mil vezes
mais rápidos que os atuais
eu fui aluno de 15 anos de idade tempo
estranho chamado de israel que escreveu
um livro muito interessante chamado é
exata das máquinas espirituais e eu
disse que em 2035 faltam sensivelmente
maior poder computacional do cérebro
eu não sei se a profecia está certa ou
errada mas também a consciência que o
conjunto dessas variáveis evolução
computacional tem um impacto
extraordinário na sociedade e no
equilíbrio dela e por isso não quis
deixar procurar justamente estes factos
que são desafios atuais sobre a vida
sobre as ciências da vida
nos últimos anos eu quero engenheiro
a próxima chance da vida são muito mais
interessantes que foi apenas 30 anos
descobrimos 30 e 40 anos que cobremos
angola em lã
vazio da vida foi isso aconteceu em
cambridge
com o título entregue foi menor por
causa disso com base na descoberta do
governo descobrimos a genômica e
proteômica felipe nome
e significa que vamos a caminho de com
base no estudo das proteínas que giram
os lípidos geramos são nós somos as
verdadeiras máquinas processadoras do
próprio na sede das olimpíadas
nós vamos conseguir construir ou fazer
nem equipamentos personalizados que já
são para ti
oprah que não são para a curva de gauss
nós todos
isso significa que estamos perante uma
nova revolução na medicina a chamada
medicina personalizada que só foi
possível justamente por causa das
américas da genômica proteômica
limpidamente se está a travar ainda mais
interessante verificar que há quatro
anos um outro que foi meu professor ana
natal universidade da singularidade um
senhor chamado craig venter que é um
gênio e se descobriu vida artificial
basicamente fez o trabalho de deus pegou
numa matéria é tradição informação e
produziu a primeira bactéria sync zava
feita pelo homem
ou seja fez visita oficial desde então
criou se uma disciplina chamada biologia
sintética que permite entre outras
coisas fazer fabrica celulares se geram
a partir daqui são imensas
a última coisa que eu queria falar
nestes nestes live é sobre uma técnica
que tem apenas 24 meses dessas meses
sinceramente não sei precisamente
quantos meses tem até quem chama de
técnica cristo e é uma técnica que
permite editar o h1n1 se o governo fosse
uma linguagem com esta técnica podemos
por exemplo potencialmente iluminar as
doenças são estritamente de vitórias
podemos março elas tal maneira que elas
não ocorram mais promissor
a maior parte dos cientistas com o
menino meu lado intelectual e graças a
deus que grande parte dos cientistas não
quase todos têm um enorme ao meu lado
intelectual divisão que ninguém sabe
qual é consequência disso próprio
sistema porque quando se mexe num
ecossistema num sítio
aparece e foi em muitos outros sítios
que nós não sabemos como sugam e
portanto não sabemos se utilizar a
técnica ea técnica cristo é boi vai ou
não
a única coisa que se quer dizer com este
lado é que as fronteiras da vida já não
são os mesmos e nos últimos anos nós
mudamos completamente isto só para dar
um exemplo mais uma vez nesse curso em
que tive a sorte de estar quatro dias a
pensar na medicina nos próximos 30 anos
eu apertei a mão uma pessoa que era
militar e prendendo um braço e um braço
biônico que tinha todos os graus levado
meu braço - longe e depois tinha mais
outros conseguiam usar a mão
completamente coisa que eu não conseguia
fazer quando fui pro paraná 1 e
obviamente tem algum medo e eu sou disse
antónio organismo que eu já sei usar
isto apesar da máquina ao foi uma porto
mano profundamente humano
apesar do pior nico foi humano quero
falar finalmente de opções e do
conhecimento não se tem noção disto mas
30% é um número que mark robson cento e
crescimento anual em cada disciplina
quer dizer que em três anos ao sucesso
do empreendimento é sempre centro
composta quer dizer que em três anos nós
julgávamos que o diploma mas não temos o
diploma que educa
isso quer dizer que já não há empregos
para a vida que ela pergunta que é minha
mãe fazia quando era pequeno que quer
ser quando for grande já não faz sentido
nós vamos fazer muitas coisas diferentes
durante a vida e vamos ter de viver com
isso pra mim é uma grande implicação é
que todos temos de estar toda a vida
o problema isso está a verificar se já
sabe ficar com o cocera 'com e com todos
os cursos online chamado a atenção porém
que é gerado não está preparada para
isto a maior para nós não está habituado
a esta idéia
e mais temos de poupar dinheiro que
investimos em 9 para todos e foi
não seremos capazes de pagar o
investimento os governos não tem
dinheiro pra fazer isso quero terminar
com palavras simples há pouco sabe há
poucos dias não trabalhados morreu assim
ele se chama zygmunt bauman escreveu
muita um solo escreveu muito sobre o
lado negativo das tecnologias
vocês lembram que os mais velhos que
estão mais na minha vaga que antigamente
nós chamávamos social ir ao café os mais
jovens chamam social partilhar amizades
entre camas com milhares de pessoas no
twitter e no facebook
eu não consigo ver isso deve ser por
isso que meu filho chama copa
o val mãe dizia que vivemos num mundo de
relações líquidas em que já não há
relação estruturante cada vez menos
mundo não são sólidos não tem valor
tem pouco valor e isso é muito fraco
francisco orlando se deu porque era um
grande homem e falou até convicon
provavelmente muito pouco falar vou
terminar apenas somente o anos um
problema que é um problema de um grande
bar dos estados unidos o outro veículo
o frango pessoas nos estados unidos e é
um problema simples a mensagem vai
passar simples e agora mas eu tive
algumas palavras que irão permanecer no
vosso pensamento em nossa memória
o rasi conclusão de toda a meta física
assim falou aos alunos do velho
professor ao extra um animado curso após
ter estudado bank que o novo sistema
grande o germânico estudado e dissertar
sobre kant fitch shelly girls posto
sabedoria platão e sócrates ainda maior
que o botão e maior que só causa do
divino cristo a qual longamente dickey
lembrou hoje os sistemas grego eo
germânico
observe todas as filosofias as igrejas e
doutrinas cristãs mas agora - sob o nome
de sócrates vejo claramente sob o nome
do divino cristo
o terno amor do aumento do seu
companheiro atração do amigo amigo do
esposo ou esposa amava dos filhos filhos
pais de cada cidade
aquela terra porque terra
esta é base de toda a metafísica do
vídeo eu encontro no futuro muitas
fontes de inspiração brasileira - é
gratificante ter sido um pouco estranho
logo a seguir uma pessoa que fala sobre
o grafeno e sobre anotou o segundo
quebra em toda uma uma nova avenida do
conhecimento
mas da mesma maneira que eu digo isso
também vos digo que espero que este
futuro que estamos a construir um futuro
anunciando aumento rápido seja também o
possa ser mais treino
é precisamente isto que apresentam essas
duas etapas que são design cleusa são
transparentes são iluminadas estão a
olhar uma pra outra com empatia eram as
respostas que queria partilhar com vocês
muito obrigado por exemplo despencaram
[Aplausos]